John for anyone who one day plans to
sell their film if you had a chance to
sit them down and have sort of a
heart-to-heart with them keeping with
the sort of Pollyanna Rose madrasahs
mentality which is good some people
don't like too much realism I like that
so before they invest thousands of
dollars in this project and years years
of their time what would you want them
to know well I would want them to know
that no one's gonna come and hand them a
pile of cash at the end of the process
and say thank you very much that's so
wonderful that you did this and you know
we're all really happy and here's your
money back and here's a wonderful
audience for you like that's number one
you know and the sooner people recognize
that and realize that I guess the second
number two is that understand that
audience building takes time you know
and shouldn't be just for one project
but you should think and conceptualize
how your audience how you're going to
engage with your audience throughout
your career and hopefully bring those
people from one project to the next and
then yeah I'd say and then the third
thing is I guess related to that is you
know to start the process as early as
possible you know and that if they can't
do it bring on someone as part of the
process to help you know doesn't
necessarily always have to be in the
beginning you know doesn't always have
to be but I think you want to at least
conceptualize the conceptualize your
audience engagement path at the
beginning whether you engage it at the
beginning or not is one thing that you
want to at least conceptualize a version
of that at the beginning so that you can
then create materials that you'll need
later for that engagement process and I
would just say number four is that you
know to take advantage of the tools that
are available to expand the storytelling
process that are now
to really think about you know to think
more expansively in terms of how
audiences engage with story and to think
that potentially there's a win when in
terms of having your audience engaged
with your story throughout the process
with you and what that can result in in
terms of the audience of owning that
process with you and how that will
benefit you as a filmmaker and I think
it's important you know as much as
possible for filmmakers to get beyond
this notion that you know and I've been
I've suffered from this notion many
times myself being a director and
especially coming out of the very strong
resurgence of the auteur theory in the
80s with Scorsese and Spike Lee etc you
know that while there is a role of the
director in terms of knowing you know
what the project is about and being a
guiding principle and having the vision
for the project you know I think it's
equally important for directors to be
open to collaboration and ideas they
just have to be strong enough and
talented enough to filter and make sure
that those ideas fit within their vision
and to not just think that you're only
collaborators are your crew and I think
the smart smart directors do collaborate
with their crew but now what is new is
that there's potential to collaborate
with your audience and that oftentimes
you can get amazing content and ideas
from your audience as much as from your
crew collaborators like even bomb it a
lot of that was crowd-sourced like I
would say 70% of the music of bomb it
was crowd-sourced you know and not and
we did it in a more primitive fashion
because the the Internet tools weren't
really available for it at the time but
we did it on a basis of just calling out
to people and putting calls out to the
internet etc in a very
rudimentary fashion because this is like
remember this is 2007 so it's like six
years ago now and it's backward in my
space what was the thing and Facebook
barely existed so you know those are
centuries and in the digital landscape
and so that's why I would say is to be
you know yeah I don't know where that
fell in the 1 2 3 4 but yeah I guess
would be to collaborate with your
audience as much as your crew
you